le 22 octobre dernier il ya amandine
bijoux qu'ils allaient pousser un coup
de gueule sur notre plateau après avoir
été évincé d'une compétition régionale
sont des explications
elle avait dénoncé la dictature de la
maigreur qui seraient imposées aux
candidates à l avez dit elle avait reçu
un sms d'un membre du comité qu'on avait
montré d'ailleurs à l'antenne pour lui
demander d'atteindre une taille 38 fait
le maximum pour arriver à une taille 38
et tout ira bien je le pense et suite à
cette polémique est une membre d'un du
comité régional qui a claqué la porte de
miss france elle explique cela ne rentre
pas dans les critères moraux je ne fais
pas espérer les jeunes filles pour qu'on
leur dise non à la porte de l'élection
régionale
mais il ya des critères officieux qui
sont donnés aux délégués de région j'en
suis certaine
alors mine de rien est ce que c'est vrai
qu'il faut faire absolument 1,38 pour
être miss france non non je pense que je
suis là pour en témoigner je faisais pas
en 38 quand j'ai été élue miss france
j'en fais toujours pas
j'ai quand même été élu le critère que
l'on demande c'est d'avoir une
silhouette harmonieuse
on reste dans un concours de beauté et
c'est ça qu'on demande aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir d'avoir quelque chose
d'harmonieux quelque chose de beau il ya
des modes dans le corps des femmes
on l'a vu à l'antiquité les femmes
étaient plus rondes pendant un moment
c'était la mode est rejeté très gros
seins bref il ya eu plein de phases suit
la mode c'est d'être plutôt minces
pas forcément très maigres mais c'est
vite comme on a vu voilà le sms qu'elle
avait reçus ou le manque du comité lui
dit de faire une telle conduite c'est
benjamin
bien sûr il vous avait appelé c'est vrai
voilà l a pas été du tout évincé cette
jeune femme elle a participé à une
élection départementale a pas été élu
moi je veux juste rappeler ça c'est
qu'on empêche pas les jeunes femmes de
se présenter par contre on se met pas on
substitue pas au public
cette jeune femme elle n'a pas été élue
smith départemental de ce fait elle n'a
pas été sélectionné pour la régionale
corps et si vous ne gagnez pas la
départementale vous pouvez être repêché
le délégué peut repêcher des dauphines
elle n'a pas évoqué les deuxièmes ils
les privent est troisième c'est vrai ou
pas ouais c'est vrai iliad plusieurs
femmes qu'elle avait parlé à la gagnante
de l'élection départementale
non mais non mais c'est intéressant dans
cette jeune femme est une ancienne ronde
qui a gagné devant elle et moi je les
retrouvais avec son miss bretagne est
sur scène elle a dit devant les
téléspectateurs
merci parce que grâce à vous moi qui a
été victime de harcèlement quand j'étais
gamine et ben vous avez montré que
malgré des rondeurs si une jeune femme
qui a des rondeurs celle qui avait gagné
l'élection de justement répartis on va
voir on va voir même physique quand même
avant même la miss france actuelle va et
madame à chaves l'an dernier mais voilà
elle avait fait un discours très engagé
lors de son élection en s'étonnant
décembre dernier regarder chavez
j'ai 24 ans j'ai longtemps été vendus et
c'est quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
de partager aujourd'hui j'ai confiance
en moi et je m'accepte il est à la
portée de tous de faire pareil
alors si je peux être porteuses d'espoir
c'est avec grand plaisir que je le ferai
merci c'est vrai qu'elle avait chez du
public car elle a l'air vraiment elle a
fait une belle fait une belle saison
dieu bénisse et c'est vrai que voilà
alors on voit jamais de femmes ont de
mine de rien sur le podium
est ce que c'est le public qui ne votent
pas pour elle comment ça se fait alors
papa on va pas rentrer dans le détail de
qu'est-ce qu'un standard français
d'accord les ports de vous le créez vous
écris un nom à une élection il peut une
jeune femme qui fait 1,3436 et souvent
n'est pas élue par le public parce que
les gens qu'on la trouvait trop mince
d'accord c'est ça marche dans les deux
sens attention il faut pas stigmatiser
veut pas dire on exclut les jeunes
femmes qui sont trop rond moi
personnellement je fais le tour de
toutes les régions de france et une
jeune femme qui apparaît sur scène et
que je trouve trop mince je la seleccion
pas parce que comme dit camille ce
qu'est ce qu'on aime on aime les jeunes
femmes harmonieuse moi j'aime les filles
qu'on déforme
j'aime les filles qu'ils la chine alors
j'aime les filles sportive j'aime les
filles tonique dynamique mais on a
chacun notre perception
en attendant c'est le public qui vote